Iranian State media is reporting that
authorities have arrested 12 members of
an opposition network with links to
Europe the Revolutionary guards accused
the group of planning acts of sabotage
in coordination with
counter-revolutionary agents in Germany
and the Netherlands the arrests in Iran
took place as shopkeepers and truck
drivers across the country are taking
part in a three-day strike that began on
Monday
rows of shuttered shops in cities across
Iran it's a sign of just how far the
anti-regime protest movement has spread
after more than two months of
demonstrations and violent pushback from
the state
in this Bazaar in Tehran some shop
owners said the authorities had warned
them not to join the Nationwide strike
among those who have stayed open there's
still support for the protest movement
this is a legitimate demand and they
should be heard
the strike comes as one top official
announced the morality police would be
disbanded and the enforcement of strict
dress codes for women has seemingly been
scaled back
it's much better without the morality
police on the streets
seeing more women walking around without
a hijab almost like they can decide for
themselves
I think that's an improvement
opposition to the religious Force has
been at the center of the protest
movement that has since grown into a
resounding call for regime change
but activists say the morality police
have just been replaced by other
security forces in the streets and state
media has since backtracked casting
doubt on whether the group has been shut
down at all
they are in fact not scrapped the news
was misreported and even if the morality
police are scrapped this misinformation
has has worked in favor of the regime to
distract folks and distract the movement
to distract International solidarity
from forming because anyone who knows
Iran knows that the morality of police
is not the problem
the head of Iran's Judiciary said anyone
caught encouraging this week's strike
will be arrested but these threats are
falling short with so many Iranians
willing to risk their lives and their
freedom to call for an end to the regime
because Abdullahi is an Iranian
journalist and photographer she took
part in the mass protests in her Tehran
and fled to Germany just a few weeks ago
thank you so much for joining us on DW
today I'd like to start by asking you to
share with us if you would some of your
experiences when you were out on the
streets protesting
hello and thank you
uh well um before right before I came
here
um I participated in protests in a
street as well as many people
and
I can talk about one experience that I
had one day in a protests in the streets
well we went to the streets and uh
we were walking
after minutes of walking
we looked behind us and there were so
many people behind us like 200 people
and we were all walking slowly in
silence
and then just in a second the guards
came and uh well we had we we ran away
we had to run away
um
well and uh I got shot by a paintball
bullets
and they hit me I fell down on the
ground and
oh
one guy he opened his car and shouted
that uh come to my car and so I went to
his car and uh I was in the car and the
guards came around the car and started
shooting to the car and hitting the car
and I was just one glass away from
resting getting getting arrested by the
police
gazelle your description there is really
powerful I can I can hear in your voice
just how how terrifying a situation that
was and so I'd like to ask you why you
joined the protests clearly you knew
people know the danger they're they're
putting themselves uh into what made you
so determined to protest on the streets
um well first of all uh my mother she's
a political prisoner and she has been a
women's rights activist in Iran and she
she has been in prison for two years
so uh
this is one reason and the other reason
that's most more important reason is
that
I'm one of so many people in Iran that
wanted to see a change
and
well everyone is now participating in
protests for the cause of change to see
the change
and
we only have our lives to exchange for
freedom
gazelle the the protests have been going
on for nearly three months now do you
feel like they're making a difference do
you and do you feel that they're as
strong as they were when they first
started or in fact are they even
stronger
um
uh of course from the start uh people we
started uh so strong and still going so
strong uh people are getting smarter day
by day
changing uh the vase they're protesting
they're striking and uh yeah
everyone is getting stronger in Iran
people
has the power now
can I ask you about the attention that
is being focused on these protests the
they're being watched across the world
um are activists in Iran aware of of the
solidarity and support and and really
what would you say what else needs to be
done from the outside to support the
protests in Iran
oh well um All the known activists in
Iran uh they got arrested since the
protests started uh even uh just the
people uh just the normal people uh that
were fighting for the for their rights
uh got arrested
so people in the streets who are
participating in the protests and
everything uh yeah
the solidarity here gives them hope they
see the videos and the protests here and
it just give them so so much hope
it it makes them stronger when they see
all these people uh
outside of country outside of Iran
Abdullahi thank you so much for talking
to us today and we wish you all the very
best
thank you